fin de vacances studieuses pour ces
jeunes norvégiens dans cette classe de
cp ce matin on revoit des notions de
français
vois-tu on avait un ace donc s'est
offert hier le travail se fait autour du
français des mathématiques exclusivement
et sur cinq jours donc nous avons 3 3
heures par jour y compris de mercredi
alors proposé pour les aider à reprendre
confiance et à retravailler certaines
bases de manière à aborder la rentrée
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
des enseignements qui s'inscrivent dans
le cadre des vacances apprenantes initié
par le gouvernement 27 élèves ont repris
le chemin de l'école pour cette dernière
semaine sur toute la période estivale 60
morts patients ont retrouvé enseignants
et copains l'idée c'est de donner un
coup de pouce à des enfants qui peut
être avait eu moins de facilité
d'apprentissage pour préparer au mieux
la rentrée
donc c'est ce qui s'est passé en juillet
et en août
ici à maurepas ils ont été détectés par
leurs enseignants puisque on a des
enfants qui viennent de toutes les
écoles de maurepas qui était au mois de
juillet à l'école de la mer me donne l
école des friches et au mois d'août à
l'école des friches ça se passe vraiment
bien les enfants sont heureux
d'apprendre d'avoir justement ce stade
une réussite
de continuer justement est à niveau en
français comme en mathématiques elle la
rentrée des classes se déroulera mardi
1er septembre
plus de 160 mille enfants sont attendus
dans les écoles yvelinoise